hey everyone Diavolo here and in today's
video we're diving back into the creative
and ever-expanding world of jujutsu kaisen.
To do this we're going to start exactly where
the anime has left us at the end of the death
paintings arc or more specifically right before
the start of currently my second favorite arc and
the greatest backstory to any character introduced
so far throughout this world. This here is
the heartbreaking and tear-jerking but yet
still somehow beautiful Gojo past arc or hidden
inventory arc of jujutsu kaisen, of course if you
are new around here and want to watch other
explained content just like this, but for a
variety of different series then make sure you hit
that subscribe button and also be sure to leave
a like on the video as it really helps out with
their algorithm and pushing my stuff to a bunch of
new amazing people but anyway enough of that let's
finally get into the world of jujutsu kaizen.
So as the arc starts off we find ourselves
12 years earlier in the past with a younger
and still voluptuous grade one sorcerer Mei-Mei
along with the second grade sorcerer Utahime,
where they have been tasked to investigate
a cursed mansion in Hamamatsu city.
Unfortunately both of them get caught within
a barrier that somehow overlaps space itself.
The girls deduce this after traveling inside of
this mansion for 15 kilometers without seeing any
of the markers that they had left behind. After a
moment, Utahime decides that they should split up
and move more unpredictably to escape the
barrier; however just before the girls are
able to put their plan into action the house is
torn apart by the cursed technique lapse blue.
As Utahime recovers from the sudden eruption,
jujutsu high's second year student Saturo Gojo
appears in front of her, he asks if she's crying,
annoying Utahime and Mei-Mei also mocks her
asking Gojo if he would console her should the
sorcerer cry. Gojo believes Mei-Mei wouldn't
cry though and just before Utahime is able to
berate him a giant curse appears behind her,
funnily enough though instantly after
the curse appears an even larger curse
appears behind it to devour it. Also there Jujutsu
High’s second year student Suguru Geto orders his
curse to not eat the other one just yet, so that
he can absorb and assimilate it later. He tells
Saturo it's not nice to pick on weaklings like
Utahime to which Gojo points out that Suguru is
teasing Utahime without even realizing, soon after
their classmate Shoko also arrives with them much
to the excitement of Utahime. Apparently Mei-Mei
and Utahime were trapped in a rare type of barrier
that messes with space-time itself, the other
students were sent by Yaga as it was odd that
a grade one sorcerer hadn't made contact with them
for a few days. Mei Mei immediately asks where the
curtain is shocking all of these students who
had completely forgotten to put up a barrier.
Shooting back to Jujutsu Tech soon after news of
a so-called explosion that destroyed the mansion
makes the news. Grade one sorcerer
and currently the first year teacher
Masamichi Yaga questions the three students. One
of them said that they had put up a curtain and
then left their manager behind, but Shoko and
Suguru are quick to point Gojo out; however
Gojo complains that curtains are pointless since
civilians can't see Jujutsu or curses anyway.
Suguru argues that it's important that regular
humans can't see sorcerers to provide a peace
of mind and hide the existence of curses. Gojo
believes it’s a pain looking out for the weak
but Suguru believes that jujutsu itself exists to
protect non-sorcerers; however Gojo disagrees and
hates those righteous ideals which begins to
annoy Geto. As the argument begins to heat up
Masamichi returns to the class and the boys
instantly change their outwards attitude.
He then assigns them to a mission together that
comes straight from Master Tengen, he says that
there is a girl who was a perfect match for Master
Tengen, who is known as the ‘star plasma vessel’.
Yaga tells the boys that they must escort
the girl to master Tengen and then erase her.
The boys joke with each other agreeing that Yaga
has let his promotion to the next principle of
this school drive him crazy. Suguru puts the jokes
aside though and asks if the mission is meant to
reset Master Tengen's curse technique? Gojo isn't
sure what they're referring to when it's something
that he thinks he should obviously know, Yaga
explains that Tengen is an immortal being but
his curse technique does not stop the aging
process. Once a certain age is reached
evolution will occur and master Tengen
will no longer be the same person,
Yaga explains that Tengen strengthens all of
the barriers used by both jujutsu high schools
as well as the auxiliary managers techniques.
Every 500 years Master Tengen must merge with a
compatible ‘star plasma vessel’ and re-write his
body's information. Once the body is refreshed
the immortal curse technique will stop trying
to change bodies and evolution will not occur.
Saturo compares the situation to a
digimon, which suffices in this case.
The location of the star plasma vessel has been
leaked and there are two groups that are currently
searching for the girl ;one is the cursed user
group q who wants to take over the jujutsu world
by having master Tengen lose all reason
the other is a star religious group that
worships Tengen as their god. They’re
known as the time vessel association,
Tengen and his star plasma vessel must
emerge in two days when the moon is full.
Gojo and Geto leave for their mission and discuss
why the star religious group is after the star
plasma vessel. Suguru explains that they worship a
pure master Tengen and that the merger would sully
the purity in their eyes ;however they are not a
cursed user group and Suguru believes that they
won't be major players. He says that they should
focus on repelling Q, to which Gojo believes that
they should be fine no matter what since they are
the strongest. Suguru interrupts his friend to
advise him to be less rude around his superiors,
while they discuss Satoru’s bad attitude there is
an explosion at the site where they are meant to
find the girl. Suddenly the star plasma vessel is
thrown from the building by someone from Q named
Kokun, before the girl hits the ground though
Suguru uses a flying curse to rescue her.
He asks the curse user to not make a mess
since the students already got in trouble today.
Kokun demands that the Jujutsu High students hand
over the girl but Suguru refuses, Satoru watches
from below glad that Geto made it in time.
He notices though five daggers thrown at him
and uses technique infinity to halt them another
Q soldier named Bayer confronts him and admits
that he knows the name of the famous Satoru. Gojo
taunts the soldier and says that he won't beat
him senseless if he cries and apologizes now.
Elsewhere at a similar time, Kong a
representative of the time vessel association
meets with a member of the Zenin clan to plan
an assassination of this star plasma vessel
;however the man claims that he is no longer a
Zenin and instead goes by Toji Fushiguro now.
He then accepts the contract to kill the girl.
Back at the battle Suguru effortlessly immobilizes
Kokun with a curse that wants to kiss him,
Kokun promises to quit being a curse
user and grow rice on the countryside
if Geto lets him go. Suguru ignores him, further
irritating Kokun and the Q soldier threatens
that Bayer Q’s strongest soldier will come and
kill them all ;however Geto soon shows Kokun
a picture with Bayer defeated on his phone.
With Q’s strongest soldier defeated
the organization soon disbands,
meanwhile Kong from the star religious group
finds Toji betting on a horse race. Apparently
he used 30 million yen in advance to wear
down Gojo and the sorcerer with him. Slightly
confused by his actions the representative needs
to bring back a report to his client and remains
skeptical of Toji ;however Toji is confident
he'll get a return on their money for sure,
but he ends up losing some of his bets on the
horse races. The representative reminds the
sorcerer that he's counting on him and before
he leaves he asks Toji how Megumi is doing.
Yet Toji literally couldn't care less and he
can't even remember who that is at this point.
Back with Gojo and Geto we are finally introduced
to Riko who awakens in Satoru’s arms and
immediately attacks him. She believes them to be
her attackers until her caretaker Misato arrives,
all three of them then get on the same page
and Riko begins to discuss her connection to
master Tengen. In casual fashion though the
two boys ignore her and then she realizes
that she's currently running late for school.
Rather than take her back to Jujutsu high now,
Riko ends up back at Renchoku girls high
school. Due to the orders from master Tengen
they are told to oblige Riko's requests because
she will no longer exist after this merger. It
is their mission to allow her to enjoy herself
which Misato is thankful for, moments later Suguru
checks his surveillance curses and realizes that
two of them had already been taken out. They both
head off to find Rico immediately while at the
same time two curse users trespass on the campus.
It is revealed that Toji had used a dark website
for curse users to place a 30 million dollar
bounty on Riko's head and these men have come
to collect their bounty. Elsewhere, Toji sits
on the phone with Kong while eating at a dumpling
stand, he learns that these sorcerers protecting
Riko have not returned to Jujutsu high. This is
good for the time vessel association because now,
more than just total lunatics will go after
the bounty. The representative points out
that the 30 million paid to him was a service
fee so if someone else kills the star plasma
vessel Toji may end up losing all of the money.
Fushiguro though isn't worried as he knows Gojo
will take care of anyone who comes after them.
This is obviously for the FACT that, Satoru is
the first in a hundred years of the Gojo family to
wield both these six eyes and the limitless curse
technique. Toji isn't even sure that he could
take out the star placement vessel with Gojo still
present. So due to this he plans on using curse
users for the remaining 39 hours of the mission
to wear down Gojo's group. Pretty much, it will be
free labor since no one will be able to cash in on
the bounty. The representative realizes that this
makes the limit of two days turn in their favor,
additionally it makes it easier
for them to gather cursed users.
Toji says they are moving faster than he expected
and he'll move out soon as well, he tells the rep
to have that 30 million ready but the man wants
to talk about his family which disinterests Toji.
Over at Renchoku Girls Junior High ;Satoru,
Suguru and Misato moved to find Riko, who was at
a musical class. Suguru plans on heading straight
for the intruders while Satoru and Misato split up
to find Riko. Gojo was irritated because he wanted
to stay close to the girl, Misato apologizes as
Riko didn't want to be seen with boys at an
all-girls school. At the same time, Suguru
splits off on his own wondering who these curse
users could be with. Without Q around hired muscle
for the time vessel association could be trouble.
Geto makes a turn down a hallway and encounters
an old gentleman who immediately covers his
front and rear with Shikigami, the cursed
user recognizes sugar's uniform and assumes that
there are multiple opponents. Geto notices this
and understands that his opponent knows what
he is doing, his opponent analyzes him as well
recognizing the student's curse technique as some
sort of cursed manipulation. The old man keeps
up his conversation with Suguru while plotting
to get in to a close range ;however Geto tells
him to not waste his time and instead uses his
giant worm-like curse to fill the entire hallway.
Suguru believes he's won, but the cursed user
appears from the window behind him using the
blind spot his opponent created to his advantage.
He gets within close range of Suguru and believes
that he has the advantage ;however his life
randomly and instantly flashes before his eyes,
Suguru then dominates the old man in close
quarters and beats him senselessly with a
ferocious succession of quick strikes.
He recognizes that the old man wanted
to get in close and states that fighters who are
presented with a single way to win are easily to
manipulate. He questions the old man asking if he
is aligned with Q or the time vessel association.
Elsewhere the others continue to head towards
Riko who is currently in the chapel (not the music
room). Gojo barges into the chapel yelling for
Riko, surprising everyone inside and embarrassing
her. The young girls inside are so enthralled by
how cute Gojo is so that they start asking Riko
questions. Gojo even takes over sunglasses
for them annoying Riko with his confidence.
The teacher makes the girl settle down and
momentarily scolds Gojo before giving away her
number. While the other girls continue to argue
Satoru grabs Riko and escapes the chapel with her.
She's annoyed he didn't follow her request
but he explains to her that curse users
have attacked the school, Gojo wants to
head straight for Jujutsu high but as he
runs across one of the rooftops with
a girl he is spotted by a curse user.
The curse user though doesn't recognize him but
recognizes the girl, Misato confronts the curse
user from behind and asks if he is with the
Time Vessel Association or Q. They engage in a
short scuffle but it ends shortly after as Misato
beats up the man by striking him below the belt.
Geto arrived shortly after,
completely surprised by her strength.
Based on the conversation, the paper bag curse
user is able to confirm that the girl he saw
is the bounty. Suddenly he melts into a puddle of
mud making Misato question actually a Shikigami!
Suguru calls Satoru and informs him
that there is a 30 million yen bounty
on Riko's head with a time limit
on a dark website for cursed users.
Satoru understands and hangs up the phone
immediately, as he and Riko are surrounded
by four of these same curse users. Riko also
thinks that the person uses clones as shikigami,
while Gojo says that their opponent should be a
Jujutsu sorcerer. The dude casually re-fuses and
forms a fifth clone claiming being a professional
sorcerer is more dangerous than it's worth.
While the new doppelganger is forming Gojo attacks
quickly and uses his curse technique lapse blue to
take out two people in an instant. Riko notices
that the shikigami haven't been dispelled,
but Gojo corrects her saying
that they are not shikigami
instead they are clones of the real caster.
Two of the clones get in close to Satoru,
but they can't bypass his infinity making
them easy prey for a counter-attack.
Thanks to his six eyes Gojo was able to deduce his
opponent's curse technique and decides to divulge
his own. This allows him to freely create a
magnetic force that brings the curse users closer
to him. Satoru attempts to unleash the advanced
version of RTC to eliminate his enemy, but it
doesn't work. Instead he is forced to knock
out his opponent with a punch, confusing
Riko. (This is cause if it was a curse like she
thought, Gojo using RTC would have allowed him
to exorcise the curse, BUT he was just a human
so Gojo had to knock him out with his hands. You
learn more about Advanced versions of RTC later in
the series but this is the first use of it here.)
Suddenly she gets a text with a picture of Misato
captured by the enemy. Suguru apologizes to Riko
and Gojo for leaving Misato behind without
considering her importance to the enemy.
Saturo believes that their enemy will try to pull
off a trade, he knows that they have the upper
hand and plans now on coordinating with their
opponents to rescue Misato. Riko refuses because
she hasn't gotten to say her goodbyes yet and
worries that the merger will happen beforehand.
Gojo assumes that the enemy will contact
them soon and agrees to bring Riko along,
as long as she isn't scared or lowers
the chances of Misato’s survival.
The kidnappers demand Okinawa as their meeting
spot, once there the group is easily able to
rescue Misato and apprehend the kidnappers. Now
at the beach Misato apologizes to everyone for
being captured by a non-sorcerer member of the
time vessel association. (Which I cant lie is the
biggest L on her behalf) Suguru like the legend he
is right now in the story, RIP movie Geto, shares
blame with her and explains that they were able to
travel safely on a plane aided by their abilities.
Still, they wondered why Okinawa was chosen
as their mating spot and Misato suggests that
maybe it's so that they could attack the airport
;however it was explained that Jujutsu high took
precautions by sending in the other first year's,
Yu Haibara and Kento Nanami to guard the premises.
While both of them are committed to do their duty
at the airport, Saturo messes around with Riko and
the others at the beach. There he decides to
its best to leave tomorrow as itl avoid more
unnessercary interactions with curse users.
Suguru though was worried that Gojo’s curse
technique is taxing his body, but Gojo assures him
that he’s fine and his presence makes everything
okay. Our airport squad are totally thrilled to
learn that they also have to stay one more day...
Now on the final day of the escort, Riko
successfully reaches the foothills of
tokyo Jujutsu high four hours after her bounty is
lifted. They pass through a number of tori-gates
putting them inside Tengen’s barriers. Ah yes
finally now with the mission almost complete
Gojo deactivates his six eyes technique
;however as soon as he does... he's also
stabbed from behind by no one other than
the demon himself Toji Fushiguro. Satoru
asks if he knows this man from somewhere, but
Toji tells him not to worry about remembering
some guy's name. Gojo slightly recognizes Toji
because earlier on in life while still with the
xenon family Toji once went to see the young Gojo.
Back then he was a big deal and was the first
and last person to ever notice Toji's
presence while standing behind them.
Back in reality Toji had waited
until Gojo was worn down to strike,
stabbing him from behind in a complete
surprise. Satoru forces himself up into
the air and Suguru summons his giant man eating
hookworm curse to devour the sorcerer assassin.
Suguru rushes to his friend's side but
Gojo assures him that his wound isn't too
severe as he reinforced it with cursed energy
to reduce any further damage. Gojo asks Geto to
take Riko to Tengen's place while he takes care of
the assassin. Listening to him, both he Riko and
Misato then leave the area as Toji slashes his way
out of the giant curse exorcising it. Toji looks
around for the star plasma vessel and claims he's
getting rusty for not killing Gojo in one blow.
Saturo taunts Toji stating that the bounty has
been lifted, but Toji reveals that he is the one
who had made the bounty in the first place.
He finds it funny how they went to Okinawa
and adds that he had to create an opening with the
illusion of goals using the time limits he set up.
No sorceress from Gojo's side were killed but
Toji still managed to get him to deactivate
his curse technique. In retaliation
Satoru unleashes his curse technique,
lapse blue on Toji. Sending him flying
using the magnetic field of attraction;
however Toji is fast enough to evade the
technique. This makes Gojo realize that Toji
has absolutely zero cursed energy meaning he's
using nothing but an innate physical prowess to
fight. (Think of Yuji before the dude got
cursed energy or the path Maki went on)
Satoru notes that he can't read his moves but
he is able to knock him away. Once he advances
he recognizes that his opponent knows about the
limitless technique and likely has a plan for it.
Toji disappears into the nearby buildings
and because Satoru can't sense him without
cursed energy he decides to clear the area of all
possible blind spots using the cursed technique
lapse; maximum cursed energy output blue. The
student believes his enemy may be hiding in
the forest and is surprised when a group of
random small fly heads appear. He believes
they've been kept in the same cursed spirit that
had been storing Fushiguro’s weapons and Toji's
plan might be connected to the curse tool he just
took out. With his view still blocked by this mock
grenade of Toji’s, Gojo plans on using blue again
until he realizes that Toji might have actually
left and gone straight after Riko. Suddenly Toji
appears behind him, Satoru notices in time and
his six eyes recognizes the foreign curse energy
flowing out of Toji's curse tool. This puts Satoru
on the defensive, almost instantly sealing his
fate. Dashing in, Toji stabs Gojo multiple times
with his special grade curse tool, the infamous
‘inverted spear of heaven’. So this item's effect
is HUGE, HONESTLY JUST REMEMBER IT! It’s effect
is the force stoppage of all curse techniques,
leaving Gojo completely defenseless. Having
connected with Gojo, Toji nullifies his technique
and cuts him down with a flurry of slashes,
leaving the young Gojo in a heap on the
ground, fully appearing to have passed on.
(Time for daddy Toji to move on in his mission of
pure destruction.) Elsewhere in the catacombs at
the bottom of tokyo jujutsu high Misato says her
final goodbyes to Riko. They cry and remind each
other that they will always love one another then
Suguru stands by to complete the escort and shows
Riko to the main hall of the tomb of the star.
Suguru then gives Riko directions to master Tengen
who is protected by a barrier that only allows
those invited inside; however before she heads off
Geto gives her an option. Either she can either
merge with the Tengen or turn back and return
home with them. So its shown that, before the
mission began both Gojo and Suguru had both agreed
that they will call the mission off if the star
placement vessel didn't agree with the merger.
Riko had been alone for most of her life and
was different from other people, her parents
had died when she was young, so she believed that
she would be okay leaving everyone behind; however
after spending time with everyone on the mission,
Riko cries and admits that she wants to stay.
Suguru offers to take Riko's hand and
take her home to which she agrees,
but sadly she is shot in the head dropping to the
floor and mortifying Suguru. As Riko's body lays
on the ground before Geto Toji reveals himself
and states that it is time to wrap things up.
Suguru asks Toji why, and Toji informs him
that he also killed Satoru Gojo. Believing him,
Suguru in a fit of anger brings out two
of his strongest curse spirits to fight.
As the battle begins, Toji begins explaining that
the majority of the barriers protecting Jujutsu
High are simply hiding it, so long as someone
knows their location in advance they could
easily locate the tomb of the star and the cursed
warehouse. Suguru attempts to attack Toji with his
rainbow dragon, but the assassin fires more rounds
at Suguru while he continues talking. Toji manages
to avoid Suguru's curse and continues explaining
how he managed to infiltrate the school.
He swallowed the curse spirit he uses to store
his curse tools allowing him to stay invisible.
Suguru interrupts Toji demanding
that stop talking as he knows that
revealing certain information can
improve his heavenly restriction,
what he doesn't know is how he tracked
them into the entrance into the tombs.
No residuals were left behind but Toji had used
more practical methods of tracking to follow them,
his lack of curse energy makes his five senses
sharpen to their peak allowing him to detect
cursed spirits. Geto asks about Misato but Toji
isn't even sure if she's dead or alive. Rainbow
dragon then attacks but this time Toji slashes it
apart with ease using his katana-like curse tool.
Suguru was shocked by this because his rainbow
dragon had the hardest skin among all of his
cursed spirits. Toji isn't impressed by Suguru’s
technique but he's suddenly caught inside the
second spirit's innate domain. This unwillingly
places Toji in a pact that will keep their
domain there until the question is answered. The
imaginary vengeful spirit asks if she is pretty
but Toji simply replies that she isn't his type.
The vengeful spirit’s domain instantly disappears,
allowing Toji to see these scissors floating
around him. Toji effortlessly deflects all of
the blades with the inverted spear of heaven,
Suguru comes in close and attempts to absorb
Toji's inventory curse but it rejects him
somehow. Toji draws a second blade from his
curse and slashes both Suguru and his cursed
spirit defeating them both in an instant.
Toji puts Suguru down and incapacitates him
claiming he would have easily killed him,
but the possibility he could release all
the cursed spirits he's taken in upon death
irritates Toji. Still unimpressed Toji
tells Suguru to thank his parents for being
born... (remember this moment for what happens
in a moment) Then saying that despite all their
blessings and abilities they all have lost to
a simple monkey who can't even use Jujutsu.
At the same time in the foothills of Jujutsu High
Gojo’s eye twitches showing some signs of life...
Over with the ‘time vessel association
headquarters house of the children of the star’
Toji delivers the star plasma vessels corpse to a
direct representative of the star religious group.
Shigeru Sonoda he confirms her passing and states
that they will pay Toji extra for his troubles.
He goes on to explain that master Tengen began
spreading Japanese Buddhism during the Nara period
and preached what would become the foundation
of Jujutsu sorcerers. The world of Jujutsu and
religion do not agree and from that disparity
the time vessel association was born due.
To this Jujutsu sorceress can't harm the group
while non-curse users are perfect candidates
to work for them, the time vessel association
couldn't afford to allow an impure merger to take
place and they are ready to fall alongside the
star if need be. Toji thinks Shigeru is crazy and
asks the man why he didn't kill the maid. Instead
of using Misato’s death he created a false sense
of security from the rescue and in turn this
helped Toji with his stuff. They used a private
jet to transport the hostage to Okinawa which
Toji and the middlemen both think is hilarious.
As the two go to leave Toji asks him to go out
for food with him but the man jokingly says that
he only associates with Toji in business
or in hell... As Toji exits the premises
he runs into a restored Satoru Gojo
and is very surprised to see someone
he supposedly killed not too long ago. Gojo
reveals that he had used a reverse curse
technique to heal himself and claims that
Toji has lost for not finishing the job.
He explains that over-using the
six eyes to process the limitless
as well as the reversed curse
technique has taxed his brain
making him delirious with a crazed demeanor and
at the very edge of death Satoru experienced and
understood the core of cursed energy itself.
Insulted by the idea that he’s lost Toji takes
out the inverted spear of heaven and claims that
the battle is just beginning. Gojo gets excited
agreeing with Toji completely, Toji attempts
to blitz Satoru slashing at him several times;
however Gojo is able to avoid them and manages
to get behind Toji and levitates into the air.
Toji turns to face him in time but Gojo learns
to flow reversed curse energy into his limitless
technique to successfully unleash the curse
technique reversal red. The explosion’s repulsion
power sends Toji flying a great several hundred
meters. As Gojo floats proudly with an insane
smirk on his face Toji acknowledges that his
opponent is indeed a monster. Toji stretches out
his arm and confirms that the energy wave Satoru
used didn't break any of his bones, he then breaks
down each of the logistics behind the technique of
the limitless and fully believes that none of them
are a problem. He connects the inverted sphere
of heaven to a chain and comes up with a plan for
each of the three distinct powers of limitless.
Even so, an uneasiness lingers over Toji...
Gojo levitates above him upside down
and wearing the same insane grin
despite having lost their previous fight.
Toji begins to hesitate but quickly calms down
and makes his move to kill the young
sorcerer swinging the chain wildly in
every single direction. Seeing this, Gojo then
apologizes to Riko because he's not vengeful for
her, as now he knows that throughout heaven
and earth, he alone is the ‘honored one’.
Toji creates a dust wave that
forces Gojo to float above it,
only for the inverted spear of heaven to appear
in front of him. Gojo thinks the attack will
likely land so focuses on countering, he
knows inherited techniques have a manual
on how to use them but it's also easy for
other clans to learn how it works as well.
He knows Toji must be a Zenin but there is one
technique only known to a few in the Gojo family;
the infamous hollow technique combines the
motion of blue and the reversal of red,
colliding those two techniques creates an
imaginary mass that absolutely annihilates
everything it touches. Having done this
exactly, Satoru unleashes the hollow
purple technique, completely demolishing anything
in its path and erasing a large portion of Toji’s
gifted body from existence. Sadly dealing
him a fatal wound and ending their fight...
Toji’s uneasiness stemmed from him breaking
his own rule he knows he should have said ‘i
don't work for free’ and made a run for it, but
the greatest sorcerer alive stood before him.
Toji wanted to discredit it and crush it.
Despite the Jujutsu world and his family,
the self-affirmation caused Toji to deviate
from his true self and at that point he had
already lost. Unfortunately for him Toji
was unable to put aside his petty pride...
Gojo asks Toji for any last words and
he initially claims he doesn't have any;
however he then thinks of the young Megumi
and tells Gojo how his son will be sold to
the Zenin family in two or three years and
to do as he pleases with that information.
Suguru makes his way to the house of the star
and is surprised to find Toji's inventory curse
injured on the ground, he goes inside to find
Satoru holding Riko's covered body surrounded by
the worshippers applauding her death. shocked by
how much Satoru has changed Suguru even questions
if he's the same person.. Gojo asks if Geto feels
like killing all of the non-sorcerers around them,
because right now in his current state of
mind he doesn't think he'd feel anything.
Suguru replies that it is pointless since
the ones in charge had fled, BUT now that
the sorcerers are still involved the time
vessel association can't talk themselves
out of the situation anymore. As a
group with problems to begin with
the star religious group will disband over time.
Gojo questions if there even needs to be a reason
but Suguru assures him that there
does, especially for Jujutsu sorcerers.
One year later in august 2007 Gojo
demonstrates to Suguru and Shoko
his ability to automatically activate and
utilize the infinity he now possesses. An
automatic targeting option for Jujutsu that
can distinguish between mass, speed, shape
and the intensity of fused energy all in order
to arrange the danger of any approaching object.
Now Gojo can almost always have the
limitless active with minimal resources,
normally doing so would fry his brain but using
a reverse curse technique at the same time
keeps him fresh. As Gojo tells them about his
other improvements Geto can't help but notice
that Gojo alone became the strongest. Now
that he can handle any mission on his own
Geto will be going on no more assignments. As well
with the last year's frequent disasters curses
spawning all over japan made it a busy summer
for the sorcerers. The endless cycle of exorcism
consumption, constantly using his cursed spirit
manipulation was beginning to weigh on Geto, he
began to lose his way due to the hideous evil of
humanity. Initially and as we all saw, he wanted
to follow through with his duty as a sorcerer
but he couldn't help but think of all of those
followers of the star as monkeys... (Which as I
hinted at before is a complete change from who he
once was, like what happened and why. Who caused
him to go insane...) Anyways after our boy takes
a shower he waits around in a room alone to think
until Yu Haibara comes to give him some company.
He tells him about his far away mission on the
next day and they discuss souvenirs until Suguru
asks Haibara if he's okay with being a sorcerer?
Haibara replies that he's not the type to think
about tough questions, but giving his all
towards something he can help with provides a
great feeling for him. Suguru agrees and suddenly
they're both confronted by a woman asking them
‘what kind of girls they are into’. The woman
walks into the room with Suguru and Haibara,
Suguru questions her identity to which Haibara
answers and claims that he can tell she's not a
bad person. He then leaves Suguru and the woman
alone and shortly after she introduces herself
as the special grade sorcerer Yuki Tsukumo. Suguru
learned about her as the special grade who doesn't
take on missions and bums around overseas.
Yuki explains that Jujutsu ends up treating
the symptoms of curses while she actually
wants to get to the root cause of it all...
Suguru is confused by what she
means by the ‘root of it all’,
so she explains that she desires a world where
curses do not exist. She asks him what are curses
and Suguru is able to explain that curses are
born from negative energy that leaks from humans
and since this is the case there are only two
ways to create a world where curses don't exist.
They must either eradicate cursed energy from all
humans entirely, or teach humans to control it.
Toji was actually a model case for the former
as he was the only person Yuki had found
all over the entire world that possessed no cursed
energy at all. His heavenly restriction granted
him enhanced senses as well as the ability
to resist curses, he truly was a superhuman.
Yuki tells Suguru that there's no shame in
losing to someone as powerful as he was.
Yuki had wanted to research him,
but every time he refused her.
Cases of heavenly restriction are so scarce,
so Yuki decided to focus on the latter option
for eradicating curses. This is because of the
fact that, other than cases where sorcerers die
and become curses, sorcerers cannot give rise to
curses. Curse energy does not leak from sorcerers
at nearly the same rate and flow as non-sorcerers,
this is due to the difference in the amount of
cursed energy some sorcerers use and how it flows
while being contained within their bodies. In a
general sense if every human became a sorcerer
it would be impossible for curses to exist..
Shocked and still haunted by the followers of
the star, Suguru asks Yuki why they shouldn't
just kill every non-sorcerer... Yet he
snaps out of it right after that thought,
still Yuki gives him a serious reply. Wiping out
every non-sorcerer to force evolution might be
the easiest route but it's also the craziest..
She asks Suguru if he hates non-sorcerers and
he's unable to give her an answer. He knows
he used to believe that sorceress existed
to protect non-sorcerers but now he doesn't
even know if humanity is worth fighting for.
Yuki confirms that Suguru must choose
between looking down on non-sorcerers
and resisting their failings, before getting
on her bike and leaving. Just before heading
out on her motorcycle Yuki says to him
that she'd like the three special grades
to get along and reveals that the
master Tengen had stabilized some
time later. (Okay so for those of you who don't
know there is a connection between Tengen and
Yuki that gets expanded on later in the series.
I think I point it of, if not and you know let
me know your thoughts on it down below or leave
a like a keep watching this monolith of a video.)
Suguru and Nanami are in the morgue
mourning over Haibara’s death,
Nanami believes it was supposed to be a simple
mission to take out a grade 2 cursed spirit;
however in the far-off area they traveled to,
the curse was the subject of a guardian deities
religion. (Interrupting again, but I think this
is the curse later used by Kenjaku at the white
house, just make’s sense to me that Geto probably
went over and picked it up after) As the deity
of that area it became more powerful,
it really should have only been a grade
one yet it wasn't. Suguru tells Nanami to
get some rest and assures him that Gojo
will complete the mission. Nanami says that Gojo
should take on every mission alone from now on.
This makes Geto think about how being a sorcerer
is like running a marathon, the finish line is too
unclear and there's nothing at the end of the road
but a mountain of fellow sorcerers dead corpses...
Next month in September Suguru is sent
on a mission to investigate a village
where a cursed spirit had been kidnapping
people and causing abnormal deaths.
Suguru is able to exercise the curse but ends up
finding two young girls who had been caged. Suguru
tries to tell them that they are not the cause of
this incident but the non-sorcerers around call
them monsters. Having heard enough Suguru
unleashes his cursed spirits on the people
and accepts his true feelings. Its later revealed
that Suguru Geto took out 112 non-sorcerers and
fled the village afterwards, the original
target of his mission was the cursed spirit
that had been plaguing a village. It was thought
to be the original culprit after of the disaster;
however further investigation revealed the
residuals from Suguru's curse manipulation.
Masamichi was tasked with giving Gojo the
horrible news surrounding Suguru and his
task to take him out. Standing there, neither of
them can make sense of what happened with their
misguided ally, with the news even making Gojo
panic internally for the first time in his life.
Meanwhile in Shinjuku, Shoko is confronted by
Suguru. There they have a conversation about
the allegations against him, even still Shoko
is quick to contact Satoru to let him know of
the traitors location. Shortly after, Gojo finds
Geto walking through the crowd in Shinjuku and
demands an explanation for all of the things he’s
done.. Having fully turned down an evil road,
Geto states that he wants to build a world
without curses and non-sorcerers. Sadly not
even Suguru's parents were spared, making
Gojo question his friends broken morals.
Geto believes in his path and because of
that thinks that there is meaning in all
of their deaths, but Gojo claims that his goal
is pointless. Again Suguru believes his friend
could easily take out every civilian by himself,
so its not impossible. He knows if they switched
places the impossible could become possible.
Due to this he decides to leave the area,
confirming to himself that this is the life
that he has chosen.. He tries provoking his
friend to kill him stating that there is
meaning in that too. As our series villan
begins to arise from the depths of grace, Suguru
walks away beginning to blend in with the crowd.
Gojo pulls up his fingers in preparation
to unleash his hollow purple technique;
however Gojo ends up being unable to kill his
best friend allowing Geto to safely escape.
He meets up with Masamichi later and reveals
that he was unable to take Suguru out
even though Gojo was the strongest. At the
building that once served as the time vessel
association's headquarters Geto comes before
a new congregation made up of the remnants of
the star religious group and like-minded
people. Suguru wishes to talk them all,
serving as priests who can free people of their
curses this way he can collect money and curses.
At the same time there are numerous voices of
opposition, so to fix this Suguru makes an example
out of Sonoda by brutally smashing him
on the stage. The next time he addresses
the crowd he isn't as friendly, instead he
demands that all of the monkeys obey him.
Elsewhere Gojo finds a young Megumi Fushiguro,
Megumi questions this strange man and asks
why he's looking at him strangely Satoru
appears annoyed because Megumi looks exactly
like Toji. As the two speak Gojo tells Megumi
that his father is from the Zenin family, this
clan loves people blessed with a hidden technique
and Megumi is approaching the age where his curse
technique will manifest which makes it perfect
time to sell him to the Zenin’s. The first grader
replies that he doesn't care about his father and
his mother hasn't returned in a while either..
Standing there Gojo asks Megumi if
he wants to go to the Zenin family,
but the boy is only worried about what will
happen to his sister if he does. Satoru taunts
him about it to get a rise out of Megumi and
when the youngster gives him a fair scourer
he insists that there is no way Tsukumi (his
sister) would be happy at the Zenin family,
he promises to take care of things for
Megumi and asks him instead to get strong...
Eleven years later in the current timeline Gojo
sensei ponders on all of these past events in
his life. Opening his eye’s, he awakens to his
three students including Megumi looking at him.
So that officially brings us to the very end
of the Gojo past arc or hidden inventory arc of
Jujutsu kaisen or whichever you want to call it.
I guess the anime is probably going with hidden
inventory by the looks of it and the manga is
sticking with gojo pasta from my memory so if
you guys have enjoyed the video obviously be sure
to check a comment down below and let me kind of
know what kind of arcs and stuff you want me to
go over in the future for different series and
all that kind of stuff the next arc that i will be
going over is going to be obviously i think it's
the bat devil arc of chainsaw man uh for all my
like tokyo avengers guys out there i've still got
the tokyo avengers like script to do oh no i've
pretty much done the script now it's kind of
just gotta like edit it up and finish it off
and then i'll be able to kind of record that
video and start editing the actual footage for it
as well uh it's just a lot longer than i expected
it to actually be as it's like 40 chapters
or something and this video was only like 15.
so you can see it's probably going to be around
an hour hour and a half long but heaps of videos
to to come in the future for like arcs explain
but just make sure you chuck down in the comment
section below so i can see kind of what series you
guys are most interested in seeing in the future
but yeah obviously this arc is extremely stellar
but at the same time it's actually pretty sad
as you kind of see gesso go from the the smarter
one i guess you could say out of the two being the
one with more brains realizing that you know they
shouldn't do specific things because it's against
the normal morals of what people should do and him
going to question his own like morals and what has
you believe in life and him going from being this
nice dude to being someone who belittles people
and calls the monkeys at the end of you know just
14 chapters here is completely utterly crazy so
you know and it hits me kind of differently you
know like on some days when i read through this
arc it's like damn like it's really dark at
the actual center of it like gojo did not
have a good like gojo did not have a good time
uh starting off i guess you could say at the jiu
jitsu college losing you know some of his friends
and then obviously what happens later on with uh
ghetto is just terrible you have seen the movie or
my previous youtube video but yeah anyway oh and
on there if you have noticed my other juicy carson
video got taken down another one whoa but um we're
gonna get that back obviously it's just gonna
take time as per usual it'll be back up in like
two weeks i'd say and six hour long video got
taken down [ __ ] yeah another one another one
of the books but yeah it'll be back up as well but
anyway if you guys have enjoyed the video and want
to see more stuff just like this then make sure
you comment down below like i have said a million
times before in every other old video and make
sure you leave it a like as well and if you're on
your own here make sure you know like do obviously
hit that subscribe button so you can keep up to
date with your favorite manga or just you know
anime when i decide to go over it and if you want
to kind of watch it and have a refresher or that
kind of stuff then hit it down below but if not
for now it's been your professional degenerate
diavolo and i will see you all in a bit bye